so I'm Consulting for the co the other day he's
super nervous very antsy anxiety sigh I'm watching
for him he's about to ask the question and he's
sweating us and he's about to tell me he's going
through a divorce his wife left him you know he's
filing bankruptcy one of his employees took his
money and he doesn't have anything left but no he
says Pat all of a sudden our business doubles in
size we did 16 million dollars I've never met
this kind of profit before I've never had this
kind of money before I have no clue what to do so
think his business has grown the business owner's
dream he's making more money than ever before
but he's nervous so I asked him one question
that took the conversation to a whole different
direction but by the way if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it I ask
him is your business at 16 million doubled
in size because of the current climate of the
market because of you or because of a client
or a employee so he says uh no the business
is at 16 million dollars and we're making this
kind of money because the market the market is
so hot I've never gotten this much business in my
life before I'm not doing anything different and I
didn't hire anybody new and it's not because of a
new customer I said okay do you want the good news
or do you want the bad news he says Pat I have a
feeling it's only going to be bad news I said well
I said the good news is you're about to make a lot
of money the next three six months save a lot of
that money but the bad news is this is going to go
by very quickly and your business is going to drop
50 back to what it normally has been the last
five years for the following reason the market
can change all the time there's a lot of guys in
real estate and mortgages that made a lot of money
during that 160 month economic expansion I know
a lot of people will say well no it was only 128
months interrupted by covet if there is no covet
that 128 is more like 160 150 economic expansion
so many Realtors mortgage loan officers made so
much money drove all the Lambos to Ferraris all
the cars and they got nothing left to themselves
because of the market only few of them are still
in business growing because of them so the three
questions was what the market you or last but not
least is what one client or one employee why one
client one employee say you got one client all of
a sudden brings a business to you hey you know
we got so much business going on you seem to be
able to process our business we'd like to bring 10
million dollars of our business over to you you're
doing six million a year one company brings 10
million but if that company leaves you to somebody
else you can also very quickly go from 16 million
to 6 million because that person is going to got
10 million or if you brought one sales person on
board and that's salesperson brought all their
customers from another company to you but you only
got two sales people or three sales people if that
salesperson leaves so will the revenue follow that
salesperson to whatever company they're going to
the only saving grace you have for your company to
continuously grow and I can tell you most people
don't want to hear this because most people want
the shortcut the yeah but if you don't understand
but what if what if it's because I know what to
do and I don't have to work as hard and I'm doing
the six days a week off and I want to do this
and no man you just got lucky a lot of people
get lucky there's a reason most businesses don't
make it there's a reason most business to file
bankruptcy there's a reason most businesses shut
down three five years there is a reason for that
it's a very very hard how many restaurants from 10
mile radius of where you live right now have been
around for 20 years why do you think because it's
a very very hard to run a business and those who
have been around for 20 years there's typically
a great operator behind closed doors that's
dependable reliable that's driving the company
so I'm going to come back to you here if you're
watching this you're a business owner and the
times may be good for you it may be bad for you
you may be like this guy you all of a sudden are
making more money than ever before thinking it's
because of you but it's because of the market
if you'd like to protect that so you don't ever
have to worry about that business going away for
you take inventory of what you can do to recreate
yourself as a leader as an operator as a creative
marketer as a way to make the investment into the
right people whether it's not just one client
that you're relying on you don't ever want to
have a client or a salesperson that gives you more
than 20 percent of your revenues per year if it is
maybe 25 percent my number is typically 20
if it's above 25 percent if they own fifty
percent if that guy leaves you don't really have
a business that person owns you the customer owns
you the employee owns you the market owns you you
don't own your business they own you so you got
to flip it on them you got to be so good at what
you do that the market no crisis no individual
no customer no client no sales person working for
you can dictate the future of your company if you
got value out of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel by the way if you haven't
yet downloaded minute I get questions asked all
the time on my neck I get thousands of messages
on Instagram Twitter Facebook I never get back
to I don't have the time to get back to it but
I get back to a hundred percent of my messages
on my neck because you want to connect with me
I got to give you my time you got to pay for it
if you want to talk to me or you want to talk
to Tom or other influencers and experts on my
neck about raising money about business about
recruiting about whatever it may be download the
app connect we're going to put the link below here
or somewhere here you can click on and you can
text me and I'll respond back text me and I'll
respond back in a video or we can do a 15-minute
FaceTime together if it's not me you can do with
other people on minute having said that have
a great Everybody Take Care bye-bye bye-bye
[Music]